TIM ANDERSON: Hi, my
name's Tim Anderson,
and I'm part of the Google
Play for Education team.
As a middle school teacher
in Denver, Colorado,
I was able to see first
hand the incredible impact
that technology can have
on student learning.
Today we're seeing an
unprecedented level
of adoption of technology
across all subjects in school.
From math to science, literacy
to the fine arts, more and more
teachers are taking
on technology
and integrating it into
their classroom practice
to unlock creativity
among their students
and to facilitate
amazing collaboration.
Our team here at Google works
closely with app developers.
And they often ask us,
what do teachers want?
We worked with
countless educators
to help understand
what distinguishes
a good app from a great one and
what key elements help to drive
engagement and adoption.
In this video series,
Tech Tips From Teachers,
we'll share those insights so
that educators and developers
can work together to
enable amazing learning.
We hope you'll check them out.
Enjoy them.
Thanks so much.